[Música]
actualmente vivimos bajo ciertos
paradigmas que son formas en que siempre
hemos visto la vida y que se han
repetido a través de siglos iv a través
incluso de milenios entre todos estos
paradigmas existe uno llamado el
paradigma del hombre
este ha gobernado la masculinidad desde
hace mucho tiempo y el día de hoy quiero
que reflexionemos juntos sobre él
porque es importante es importante
porque este paradigma ha hecho que
nuestras conductas como hombres sean
adecuadas a lo que la sociedad quiere
pero hay ocasiones en las que estas
conductas no sabotean nos hacen sentir
mal hacen sentir mal a aquellas personas
con las que vivimos y es por ello que
quiero que hoy reflexionemos
especialmente en este asunto vamos a ir
directamente al principio quiero
llevarte al principio literalmente
porque te voy a hablar de una historia
la historia de un personaje que hoy
llamaremos veto
que todo es un niño recién nacido
y en este momento beto no tiene ninguna
diferencia con una niña que haya nacido
a un lado de él así como otros miles de
niños
la única diferente y una niña es su
sistema reproductor
en su mente no existe ninguna diferencia
ningún rol ningún paradigma que gobierne
lo que vetó va a hacer con su vida
este caso puede ser
el tuyo de ti que me estás viendo puede
ser el de tu abuelo el de tu padre el de
tu esposo el de algún conocido y
entonces por ello es que te voy a pedir
que estés muy atento y muy atenta a esta
a esta historia quiero que imagines que
realmente imagines a beto un recién
nacido
y la mente de beto además quiero que la
imagen es como una hoja en blanco así
tal cual una hoja en blanco
cuando tienes una hoja en blanco quiere
decir que está lista para escribir
escribir en ella y así es la mente de
beto está lista para que la sociedad las
caricaturas la familia sus padres para
que todos todos alrededor de él empiecen
a escribir
qué cosas van a escribir en la mente de
beto pueden ser cosas buenas normas y
leyes que va a tener que seguir y
también van a ser escritas en la mente
de beto algunas cosas oscuras de las que
hablaremos también
bueno comencemos en algún momento
pero va a escuchar palabras bien o mal
intencionadas que llegarán a su mente
sabías que incluso podemos aprender
desde el vientre materno
algún tío o una abuela una persona bien
o mal intencionada no lo sabemos
mira aquella frase que usualmente se
escucha esta frase no importa si naciste
aquí en nuestra alcaldía de milpa alta o
si naciste en otra parte de nuestro país
aquí en méxico y en algunas otras partes
del mundo
escucharás que dirán que bueno que no
fue niña o qué bueno que fue hombre
bueno recuerda la mente de veto es como
una hoja en blanco así que esto ya se se
empieza a escribir en la mente
tal vez en ese momento no existirá
ninguna reacción conductual sin embargo
va a quedar escrito que más va a pasar
que todo irá creciendo y cuando vea
caricaturas cuando vea la novela con
mamá recibirá una imagen del
comportamiento masculino esperado
quiero que pienses como son los galanes
de la novela qué comportamientos tienen
cómo tratan a las mujeres y cómo los ve
la sociedad
quiero que pienses además en las
inocentes caricaturas que también
enviarán un mensaje a la mente de veto
sobre cuál es su rol como hombre y
hablamos de ahorita de un veto que aún
ni siquiera ha asistido a la escuela
pero la mente de veto está y sigue
recibiendo esta información porque
acuérdate es una hoja en blanco antes de
continuar quiero quiero decirte esto no
es ninguna justificación para los
comportamientos machistas o incluso
misóginos que puede desarrollar veto sin
embargo es una explicación del origen de
donde podemos intervenir de que podemos
hacer para cambiar nuestra vida y
cambiar la vida de las personas que nos
rodean como hombres
bueno cuando vetó ingresé a la escuela
por ahí de la primaria también recibirá
más mensajes mensajes que recibirán
hombres y mujeres
cuando se forma el equipo de fútbol
dirán los hombres van a jugar y las
chicas los van a animar
habrá comportamientos que las chicas no
podrán llevar a cabo porque llevan falda
a la escuela y habrá comportamientos que
los chicos se les aplaudirán como saltar
como brincar etcétera todo esto va a
seguir siendo inscrito en esa hoja en
blanco que es la mente de beto recuerda
esta historia puede ser la tuya puede
ser la de tu padre la de tu abuelo la de
tu esposo mantén la imagen de esa hoja
en blanco porque vamos a seguir
escribiendo
vamos a seguir escribiendo en la mente
de beto que más sucede con beto bueno a
beto le dirán que los hombres no lloran
imagínate nada más
lo grave de esta de esta frase que
parece y que está muy difundida la
realidad es que llorar es un acto
fisiológico un acto totalmente natural
que de hecho no todos los animales están
hechos para llorar y sin embargo a
nosotros como hombres en algún momento a
beto en especial que es el protagonista
de nuestra historia le dirán que los
hombres no lloran te dirán que los
hombres ocultan sus miedos sabías que
los niños pequeños comienzan
aproximadamente entre los 4 y los 6 años
a tener problemas para expresar sus
miedos porque principalmente porque se
exponen a burlas en la familia y ni se
diga si veto ya pasó a una etapa de
quinto o sexto grado porque si expresas
que tienes miedo tal vez te puedan ver
como un cobarde si expresas que no
quieres hacer algo porque es muy
riesgoso incluso también puedan verte
como un cobarde
los comportamientos masculinos y
machistas no están justificados sin
embargo existen explicaciones para que
los hombres no podamos expresar
realmente lo que sentimos o al menos de
la manera correcta
qué más va a pasar con beto bueno cuando
meto pase a la secundaria cuando ya
tenga atracción por alguna chica por
algún chico comenzará a ejercer
la forma en que aprendió a tener una
pareja y que sucederá bueno te decía yo
hace rato
recuerda el papel del protagonista de la
novela como es es infiel
se enoja empuja grita cela es positivo
si te suena tal vez por ahí hay alguna
explicación y tal vez hay algo que
trabajar como sociedad en lo que
escribimos en la mente de nuestros niños
en lo que se ha escrito en nuestras
mentes y en lo que vamos nosotros a
dejar a nuestros hijos porque tal vez en
algún tiempo a ti si eres padre tu hijo
te veía como un superhéroe y ahora tal
vez tiene miedo de tus comportamientos
tal vez en algún momento por miedo a
tener miedo por no poder expresar lo que
sentía lo que querías decir probaste
alguna droga o te emborrachas te como
seguramente le pasó o le va a pasar a
veto porque déjame decirte
a penas para la adolescencia
pero ya tendrá aprendido y practicado
todo este conocimiento que nosotros como
sociedad estamos compartiendo en estas
maravillosas hojas en blanco que somos
los hombres
reflexiona en un momento porque beto va
a crecer va a querer tener una pareja va
a querer tener hijos
y va a transmitir este mismo
conocimiento
es por ello que tal vez los hombres
somos más del 90% de la población en una
cárcel
es por ello que tal vez los hombres
somos quienes más ejercemos la violencia
porque no hay que negarlo es una
realidad
el 90% de las muertes violentas las
ejecuta un hombre con azufre un hombre
es por ello que esto que parecía una
historia sencilla una historia común se
vuelve algo que hay que cambiar lo más
pronto posible algo que tenemos que
transformar quiero
darte una ilustración decirte de aquel
hombre que nunca ha visto el mar
y que si tú lo no engañas de mientes le
enseñas una ilustración de que esto es
el mar tal vez te va a creer pero déjame
decirte que hay una vida distinta para
nosotros los hombres es por ello
que quiero aprovechar esta charla para
para darte un método para darte tres
pasos que puedes hacer empezar a hacer
hoy mismo tres cosas con las que puedes
empezar a actuar para que tu vida sea
mejor para que las personas se vuelvan a
ver como un gran amigo como un gran
hombre para que tus hijos vuelvan a
decir ahí viene mi padre y estén
emocionados de verte y te quieren
abrazar para que tu pareja se vuelva
enamorar de ti y no termines solo con
una pareja que ni siquiera te agrada
cuando termines en adicciones fíjate
desafortunadamente en mí en nuestra
alcaldía me falta en el consultorio
psicológico donde yo trabajo vemos
aproximadamente un 90% de pacientes
mujeres sólo un diez para diez por
ciento de pacientes hombres
esto me indica que tal vez tenemos que
hacer algo y tenemos que aprender a
vencer nuestros miedos por ello el
primer punto que te voy a poner a
trabajar y qué vas a trabajar desde
ahorita saliendo terminando de ver está
esta charla es que pidas ayuda pide
ayuda así como lo escuchas pide ayuda
si sientes que algún comportamiento tuyo
que alguna conducta que tienes está
causando problemas está haciendo que los
demás se alejen de ti si te sientes todo
el tiempo enojado molesto a veces ni
siquiera sabes por qué si estás con unos
celos extremos hacia tu pareja quieres
controlar todo lo que hace
pide ayuda de preferencia ayuda
profesional busca ayuda profesional no
tengas miedo nos han dicho que pedir
ayuda desde cobardes la verdad es que no
para pedir ayuda hay que ser muy muy
valientes entonces el paso 1 que tienes
que hacer es pedir ayuda el paso número
2 es un paso muy hermoso porque los
hombres también somos muy hermosos y
este paso número dos es amate
amate como has amado a otras personas
amate como amas a tus hijos amate como
as como has hecho sacrificios por otros
a veces hay gente que me dice he
trabajado turnos extras he hecho todo
para que en la casa nunca falte nada
bueno haz lo mismo por ti por tu piel
por tu cuerpo por tu mente por tu alma
amate amate en serio deja de pensar que
es que el amor no es asunto de hombres
deja de ver el amor de esta forma simple
y romántica y empieza a practicarlo con
quien contigo para que te ames tanto que
desbordes hacia otras personas para que
tu hijo tu pareja
para que tus padres puedan sentir ese
amor que como hombre puedes dar
y entonces tal vez tu pareja vuelva a
enamorarse de ti vuelva a darse cuenta
de todo lo grandioso que eres
tal vez tus amigos puedan darse cuenta
del gran hombre que eres y que tienes
mucho que decirles y puedas hacer un
cambio mayor aún tal vez tu hijo te
vuelvo a ver como ese gran superhéroe
que eres y tus padres no tengan
problemas con que entres y salga de su
casa en el momento que tú quieras porque
van a decir mi hijo es un gran hombre
y el paso 3 tiene que ver con dejar esa
máscara que a veces utilizamos
para defendernos ese miedo trabaja tus
miedos
sabes por qué porque a veces los hombres
trabajamos nuestras emociones con el
enojo la verdad es que los hombres
tendemos a trabajar las emociones con el
enojo si estás triste te enojas
si estás enojado obviamente continúas
enojado lo prolonga a veces incluso la
felicidad la llegamos a trabajar con el
enojo porque es una máscara que nos
hemos puesto y que nos protege
cambia no tengas miedo de tener miedo
escucha lo absurdo que se oye no tengas
miedo de tener miedo los hombres tenemos
miedo
los hombres lloramos y es por ello que
te invito a que a partir de hoy comienza
el cambio abras tus emociones a tu
pareja y a todas las personas que te
rodean los hombres somos fantásticos los
hombres tenemos la capacidad de aprender
y cuando nos demos cuenta de las
capacidades enormes que tenemos en
nuestro sistema emocional vamos a poder
literalmente cambiar el mundo con ideas
que logren inspirar a muchos y si hoy tú
eres el único en tu familia que cambia
no te preocupes quiero que te estrelles
contra todas estas cosas que las
personas te han enseñado porque no te
sirven y lo que no sirve se desecha
entonces recuérdalo pide ayuda lo más
pronto posible cambia transforma tu vida
y sigue adelante siendo un gran hombre
[Aplausos]
[Música]